une voie d'eau paisible plus un axe de
verdure c'est l'idée que les
responsables de la ville de paris se
font désormais du canal saint-martin un
canal peu connue des parisiens eux-mêmes
le reconnaissent et qui s'étend sur près
de quatre kilomètres entre la place de
stalingrad et la place de la bastille en
fait ce cas là l'objet de convoitises
son espace fait rêver et il y a quelques
années un projet avait vu le jour il le
prévoyait ni plus ni moins de
transformer le lit du canal saint-martin
en axe routier s'est pas jean verdier
alors préfet de paris que revint le
mérite et la clairvoyance de mettre le
projet au placard aujourd'hui va venir
du canal est envers les élus de la
capitale sont en train d'étudier un
dossier que l'on peut résumer ainsi plus
de voitures en stationnement sur les
berges plantation d'arbres aménagements
de jardins et des espaces verts pour les
enfants les promeneurs et les amoureux
et rénovation des îlots vétuste
tout cela bien sûr va demander du temps
et des moyens un plan d'occupation des
sols partiel sera sans doute créé sur
toute la longueur du canal un canal
saint-martin injustement oubliée et qui
commence sa toilette pour de prochaines
retrouvailles avec les parisiens